(electronic beeping)
(upbeat lively music)
- Welcome to A Conversation With History,
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest is Jennifer Granholm
who is a former governor of Michigan,
and a former Attorney General.
She is now at Berkeley
as an adjunct professor
in the School of Public
Policy and in the Law School.
Jennifer, welcome to our program.
- So glad to be with you, thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well, I was born in Vancouver,
British Columbia, Canada,
but came to the US with my
parents when I was four.
And we moved to Southern California
and then to Northern California
and I'm proud to say I'm a Cal alum.
And so that's where my parents
actually are still alive
and they are living in San Carlos.
- And looking back, how did they affect
your thinking about the world?
- Well, it's kind of
interesting you say that
'cause they never got a
chance to go to college.
They come from very humble roots
and they're Republicans, I'm a Democrat,
an active Democrat, so I often think
that perhaps it was higher
education that gave me
a wiser view of the political spectrum.
But they're also very meat and potatoes,
and while I wasn't raised in Michigan
and I ended up becoming
the governor of Michigan
because I married Michigan,
the sort of infused notion
of being very understanding
where people come from
when they haven't had
all the opportunities
is a gift that my parents gave to me.
- And you have a very value-oriented way
of looking at the political world.
Does that come from them?
- Well, it's an interesting thing.
I mean, when you say value-oriented,
they are very faithful people
in terms of religious faith.
And my dad, who is just a stoic Swede,
I never heard him utter a swear word,
I never heard him raise a voice
and I never heard him tell a
lie in any way, shape, or form.
I mean, for him, integrity was everything.
And so I feel like that
became so important to me
because I would never
want to do something,
a, that disappointed him
but that ran counter to that
sort of infused sense of values.
Now when I met my
husband, who is Catholic,
I converted to Catholicism
and the reason why
is because the Catholic
tradition that he came from
and that I really admired
was a tradition that involved
service to the poor.
And so that became a very
much a part and parcel
of how I governed and my
values and priorities,
budgetarily, in how I governed
and the people that I was able to serve.
- And your relationship with your husband
is a very important
partnership in your life,
not only did you write a book together,
"A Governor's Story," which
I will show our audience
in which we will talk
about in a few minutes,
but also he was an important partner
when you went into public service.
- Super important partner.
I mean, first of all, when we--
- [Harry] You should say his name.
- His name is Daniel Mulhern
and he's also a professor
here at Berkeley.
He teaches in the Haas Business School.
He teaches leadership as a matter of fact
which is what he ended up doing
before I became governor.
He had a business et cetera that was doing
consulting in leadership and all of that.
But he's from Michigan
and we met at law school
and I initially, I had to be
wooed, I'll just say that,
and he was really great at that,
but we're totally different people.
He's very much, he's very heart-centered,
I'm head-centered.
If you look at, I don't
know if your viewers know
what Myers-Briggs is, but it's a test
that determines your
personality types, et cetera.
We are completely opposite,
which is really great
because together we make a whole.
And he has skills and
tendencies that I don't have
and similarly I have skills and tendencies
that he doesn't have and so
it's a really great thing.
It could create tension, but once we,
once you come to love
and understand somebody,
we've been married for 33 years,
you end up recognizing that the things
that you might differ about are things
that actually can end up benefiting you.
So he has been an incredible partner
in our life and in our
marriage and in raising kids.
When he grew up he
wanted to be either pope
or president or governor of Michigan.
And when we went through
marriage prep with a priest,
the priest said to us, well, hey,
what if the party comes to Jennifer
and asks her to run for
office, what will you do?
And he was like, he grew up he was,
he went to Yale as an undergrad,
he went to Harvard Law School,
he's a jock, he wanted to be a big man,
he said, well, I'd probably be jealous,
but if she wanted to do
it I'd be behind her 100%.
And the priest was very prescient
and the party did come to me.
And Dan from the get-go was saying,
hey, the door only opens every so often;
when it does, you gotta go through,
I'm with you, I'm behind
you, I've got the kids.
'Cause when I ran for attorney general,
which was my first public office,
my youngest child, we have three children,
my youngest was only seven months old.
And so Dan was like, I got the kids,
don't worry, let's do it.
I don't think he really knew
what he was getting into
when he said that, but nonetheless
he has been an incredible partner.
- And he really assumed
the burden of raising--
- [Jennifer] Yeah, yeah.
- The children actually.
- Yeah, I mean his lane was to take care
of these little souls.
And, honestly, if you did
look at our personality types
and you compared them and you were trying
to pick someone to raise your
children, you would pick him.
Because he can stare at a baby for hours.
- So the Lord intervened (laughs).
- The Lord intervened, I guess.
I mean, it's funny because they ended up
benefiting enormously
'cause he's creative,
he's soul-centered.
So, for them, it was really important.
And it's hard to be a child of a governor
or an attorney general and
so having somebody there
who is solid, who is
there for you is really,
really important and I'm just so grateful
that he was willing to do that.
- Before you went to
Cal and to Harvard Law
you tried a number of different careers.
We don't have to go into it.
- Thank you (laughs).
- But is there a general
lesson that you acquired
from trying a number
of things before you--
- Yeah.
- Which is go and do it.
- I mean, a lot of times I think kids
at Cal 'cause I've got these young people
who want to achieve, achieve,
achieve, which is great,
but sometimes you wanna
experiment a little bit
and closing doors is a
way of making a choice.
And so to be able to try some stuff out,
even if it's wild stuff.
And if it doesn't work, what
better time to try it at least
when you are young and don't have a family
and don't have those
kind of responsibilities.
So I strongly encourage these
young people to experiment
and then figure that out, try it
and maybe it'll work, who knows.
But if it doesn't,
don't feel bad about it,
just know that it's a
stepping stone in life.
- What led you to politics and the law?
- Pardon me, what led me?
- Yeah.
- Well, I, it's funny, one
of the things that I tried
as I went to Los Angeles,
and I wanted to become
a serious actress and I was in that role,
not in that role but in that step,
I worked for Universal
Studios as a tour guide
and in between tours, I kid you not,
I would sit in the back waiting
for my tour to be called
and I was reading Will and Ariel Durant's
"The History of Civilization."
And that got me to reading philosophy
and that got me to thinking,
what the hell am I doing here (chuckles),
and really got me super
interested in politics.
My parents were not political.
I mean, they're Republicans
but they're sort of
one step removed; they're not active.
I volunteered for a political campaign,
which at that time was John B. Anderson
who was an independent.
I went door-to-door for
him, I became a US citizen,
I had started that process when I was 16,
I was the first from my family
to become US citizen from Canada.
And then that swearing-in ceremony
was so powerful for me--
- Swearing-in?
- To become a citizen.
- Oh, oh, right.
- I felt like I, this is my country now
and I have an obligation to do something.
And so the combination of
reading sort of the history,
both history and philosophy
and then becoming a citizen,
I said, I'm leaving LA and I'm gonna go
to the best college I possibly can
and take a different path.
And so that's when I was fortunate
to be able to get into Berkeley
and all is history from there.
- And then to Harvard Law School.
I like to ask, my guests, what they see
as the skills and
temperament prerequisites
for the work that they have done.
So in your case as a political leader,
what advice do you have for students
about the skills that they should acquire
and the temperament they have to find?
- Well, I think the most important
piece of advice I give to students
is if you want to run for office,
if you wanna be a leader, which is great,
glad that you wanna serve.
But most important, if you don't have,
as a personal experience,
some kind of crisis
or tragedy or a difficulty
that you have surmounted,
then put yourself in a position
to see other people's pain,
put yourself in a place to understand
what the thing is you
should be fixing out there.
Remember, if somebody, if
a young person comes to me
and says, I wanna run for office,
and I say why and they say,
because I think I'd be really good at it,
I'm good at speaking,
I know a lot of people,
people tell me I'd be good.
Like, dude, that is the
worst reason to run.
It's not about you; it's
about an authentic desire
to change the world in some way,
in some meaningful way.
And if you don't have that as your driver,
then you will never be successful or good
or have people follow you.
Nobody wants to follow you
because you speak well,
people wanna follow you because you are
determined authentically
to change something.
And so to me, that's the most important
qualification to have.
- I hear you saying that two elements
are empathy, which you just described,
but also empathy and responsibility.
So once you do it, what's involved here,
then let's get to doing it.
- Yeah.
In fact, I was just speaking
at, I was speaking to a class,
my husband's class on leadership
at the Haas Business School
and Haas has a value on the wall,
one of their values is beyond self.
And if you're gonna serve
the public in some way
you have to recognize
that it must be because
you are put here on the planet
to do something more than serve yourself.
You have to be about others.
It's not about money,
it's not about anything
other than you're putting every ounce,
every fiber of your being into
making it better for others.
- When you become governor
you come in with an agenda,
you have a set of plans,
but that's not the--
- Not always the thing
that works out (laughs).
- Right.
And so, what, you opened the
door to the governor's office
and there's crisis--
- Yeah.
- After crisis.
So what did it take
to be able to embrace that situation?
And you say in your book,
if I can find it here,
a quote that you had gotten from a friend
about endure, move forward,
I can't find it right now.
- [Jennifer] Yeah,
accept, adjust, advance.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And that's sort of
the key to what you did.
- I mean, in my case, so
I was elected as governor
during a time of massive economic shift.
I mean, it was really an
existential crisis for Michigan,
for Michigan's economy,
for Michigan citizens,
for Michigan's businesses.
We were known as the automotive capital,
we were known as a manufacturing state,
we had seven times more manufacturing,
old line manufacturing jobs
as any other state in the country.
And people came, the whole migration north
was to Henry Ford's factories, right?
And so everybody came to Michigan,
everybody's families from Michigan,
Dan, my husband's father
is 37 years at Ford,
I mean everybody worked
in the auto industry
or in one of the suppliers, I mean,
it was just part and parcel of who we are.
And so when the crisis in
manufacturing happened,
obviously there had been automation
that had been displacing jobs like
in the latter part of the last century
but it accelerated so much
and when combined with trade
and automation together it
just completely decimated
so much of who we were.
So that crisis was not
just a one-off crisis,
that was a deep structural
change in our economy.
- And we're talking about what year?
- So I was elected as governor in 2002.
So there was a national recession
happening at that point,
George Bush was president.
2003, I came into office and
it only continued to get worse.
In Michigan, the motto is when
the nation catches a cold,
Michigan catches pneumonia,
that's because we manufacture
big consumer products like
cars; when we're in a recession,
people don't buy those kind of products.
However, there's pent up demand,
and when you come out
of a national recession
then we used to do really well.
So that cycle was something
we were used to in Michigan.
But in the early 2000s, it became clear
that this was not a cyclical recession
that this was a structural change
in the real underpinnings of our economy
and that required a
different kind of leadership
which gets back to your point,
the door opens, crisis hits us in a way
that we had not anticipated,
no one had anticipated,
and boom, we had to deal with it.
- And you had to assume
all sorts of roles.
You had to be a strategist, a negotiator,
a explainer to the public,
who had elected you,
expecting one agenda and getting another?
- Right, yeah.
I mean, I think that's
true with any governor,
with any CEO that you have
to assume all of those roles.
But it is on steroids when
you are in crisis, right,
especially the part about
helping people transition
from an old economy to a new one
when their identity is tied up
in manufacturing these products
or in their father who
had worked at this factory
and their grandfather had
worked at this factory
that whole identity crisis.
When you tell them, you know what,
those jobs are not gonna come back
and you have to be retrained,
that means you're putting the work on them
when they want you to fix it for them.
And so that is a leadership moment
where you're trying to bring,
to give the work back to the people
and the people don't want to
have to do that kind of work.
So it's easier to explain it to them often
when you talk about it in
terms of their children.
So you can say to somebody
who is a factory worker
who's in their late 40s, look,
what was good enough for you,
and you made rational choices
at the time you made those choices
to go from high school to factory,
but that's not gonna be
enough for your kids.
They all get it then.
They see what's happening.
It's just the idea of
a 40-something-year-old
going back to get retrained
and having to sit next,
in a community college, to an 18-year-old
or a 19-year-old doing trigonometry
when you didn't have to take
that even in high school,
it's a diminishing thing,
it's a dignity question.
And so there has to be a response to that
that is more robust and more nuanced
and more dignified than we have
used in the past in the US.
- And this empathy thing
becomes very important
because you have factory
after factory closing
and you have to confront the workers
and go to the factory
that's about to close
and explain to them that you care
and this is what we have to do.
- Yeah.
I mean, can I, I'll just tell this story
about Greenville because this,
there's a little city
in Michigan, Greenville,
and it happened in my first year in office
and it really became
the wake-up call for me
that things were gonna
be totally different
than what I had anticipated.
So the, we had in
Michigan something called
the Michigan Economic
Development Corporation
which is the entity that saves businesses
that works with them to come.
And I got a call from the
president of that entity
at the end of my first
year in office and he said,
Gov, we got a big problem.
There is this little tiny community
in the middle of Michigan
called Greenville
and they are known as
the refrigerator capital
of North America because they have
the largest refrigerator
factory in North America
operated by Electrolux.
This town had 8,000 people.
3,000 worked at the factory.
So as you can imagine,
with senior citizens
and children et cetera,
it's a one company town essentially.
There are suppliers and
there's the factory.
And the guy from the Economic
Development Corporation
said to me, the problem
is, is that that factory
is going to move to Juarez, Mexico.
And I said, are you kidding
me, I'm the new governor,
there's no way.
So we went, I brought my
whole cabinet to Greenville
and we put all sorts
of incentives together
to offer to the head of Electrolux,
the management of Electrolux,
and it was $780 million
worth of incentives
which was massive.
Zero taxes for 20 years, we're gonna help
to build them a new factory all of that.
And they looked at our list of incentives,
they went outside the room for 17 minutes,
they came back in and said,
wow, this is the most generous
that any community has ever
been in trying to create jobs,
keep their jobs, but there's
nothing you can do, governor,
because we can pay a $1.57
an hour in Juarez, Mexico.
Now when he told us this,
this was like a nuclear bomb--
- This is the CEO.
- Yeah, this was the head
of the management team
at Electrolux who had come
in for this negotiation.
And, because Michigan had so
many of these kind of factories
when he said there's nothing you can do,
I thought, oh my God, what does this mean
for the rest of these
communities, these little towns
that are built up around these factories?
And the month that the last refrigerator
came off the assembly
line, let me just say this,
the workers at Electrolux
were so incredible
that when this was announced
that they were leaving,
and it was the newscasters,
there are tears everywhere.
But the next day, these workers showed up
with American flags on their lapels,
showed up for work on time
and they worked through
to the last refrigerator
was off the assembly line.
And that month they had this big gathering
in a pavilion in Greenville
called Klacke's Orchard Pavilion
and they called this
gathering The Last Supper.
And I went to it and I
went up to the first table
and it was just like this
massive community wake.
Everybody was grieving and
everybody's like nudging,
what are you gonna do,
what are you gonna do now,
what are you gonna do now?
And I go up to the first table
and there's this guy in his,
he's got a baseball cap
on and he's got tattoos
and he stands up and he says, gov,
he's got his daughters next to him,
he says, I want you to meet my girls.
He said, I have worked in
this factory for 30 years.
My father worked in this factory,
my grandfather worked in this factory,
I went from high school to factory.
I'm 48 years old.
All I know is how to make refrigerators.
And then he does this, he puts his hand
on his chest like this and he said,
so, gov, tell me, who
is ever gonna hire me?
- So in a year you're governing
in a context where the Republicans
have set the stage.
And they've been running
and winning on a platform
of cut taxes, less government and,
if not eliminate, then lower the expenses
of the social net.
- The social safety net.
- That increases your problem.
And, I guess, as I'm listening to you,
you, on the one hand, have empathy,
but in the back of your
head you must have a theory
of what's causing all of this.
- Well, yeah.
I mean, I will say this.
I mean, I know that it has to
do with globalization, right?
Obviously they're going to Mexico
because they can and it's cheaper.
I used to campaign on NAFTA and CAFTA
have given us the SHAFTA.
So I know why Donald Trump
won in states like Michigan
because there are the residue,
this hulking residues,
or vacant land from people from factories
that have been cleared out, right?
So I know that.
So a lot of this had to do
less with the state budget
than with external
factors that were global.
However, because these
factories were leaving
and people were finding
themselves without work,
that had a huge impact on the state budget
'cause state budgets are countercyclical.
And obviously when unemployment is high,
the needs are high but
the income to the state,
the tax receipts are lower.
So what do you do in that situation?
And when I was elected,
I say I'm a Democrat
and I was elected with a Republican House
and a Republican Senate, a
Republican Supreme Court,
a Republican Attorney General
and a Republican Secretary of State
so I was the only Democrat.
It required compromise.
I get the idea of cutting taxes
to try to make yourself irresistible,
but our corporate tax
rate was not that high.
It wasn't corporate taxes
that caused Electrolux
or any of the other factories to go;
it was because of wages, honestly.
And automation, obviously, eventually
played a big role too,
not in the early part
of the 21st century, but
certainly in the past decade
or so it's really played
a much bigger role.
I say all of that to say
that the state responses
to something like this are
really, it's very difficult
'cause what you wanna do is invest great,
more robustly in training
for those workers
but you don't have the
money to be able to do that
when all you're trying to do,
you got your finger in the dike
to at least not cut K through 12 education
or not cut healthcare
for vulnerable citizens.
It is a very difficult time.
So as governor, even
though I'm a Democrat,
I ended up cutting more
out of state government
than any governor in
the history of Michigan,
but as a proportion, than
any governor in the country
during that recession.
We ended up by 25% cutting
all the state departments,
closing down prisons, defunding the arts,
defunding all of these things.
In fact, I went around to the state,
in every media market of the state,
and I did these town halls where
I had the local station select people
who were representative of areas
where state government was facing cuts,
students, teachers, prison
workers, sheriffs, et cetera,
and I gave them all
clickers and I said to them,
okay, if I'm gonna, if you
have to make your first cut
or place your first
dollar, where would it be,
and I'd give them a series of choices.
Would you defund the arts or
would you defund libraries?
Would you defund libraries,
would you defund higher education?
Would you defund higher education,
would you defund prisons?
Would you do higher education
versus K through 12?
You have to have people realize
what the series of trade-offs are.
And so I took all of the results
of those essential focus
groups back to the legislature
'cause I also invited the state reps
that represent those areas and I gave them
what the citizens wanted.
And the citizens basically said,
if you have to cut, cut,
but don't cut K through 12
and don't cut healthcare
for vulnerable citizens,
those two things.
And I'm pleased that
despite all the massive cuts
those two things I was able to preserve,
but the only way to do it in
the face of all of the crisis
was to be able to go to the people.
- But you came in knowing
that retraining and education
were an important plan in your platform.
- Yes, absolutely.
Those were things that
I came in knowing.
- Yeah.
- But we hadn't faced the crisis yet.
Unfortunately, so I was governor also
when the auto industry
went bankrupt, right,
so our major, and before that,
the suppliers to the auto
industry went bankrupt.
And during the Great Recession in 2008,
between December of 2008 and June of 2009,
I got 1,018 WARN Act notices
and WARN Act notices, for your viewers,
are the notices that a
governor gets and a mayor gets
when a company is about
to do a mass layoff.
So 1,018 companies doing mass layoffs
during that six-month period.
So we were completely in the soup.
So, fortunately, Obama was elected
and I was able to go to the
Department of Labor and said,
can you give us a waiver
on all of the monies
that we would normally get,
'cause we have to craft
an emergency training
program for our workers
and we also have to work with
the Department of Commerce
to get international
investment in Michigan
'cause you have to have jobs
to train people for, right?
So it was a simultaneous
diversify the economy,
bring in new kinds of jobs,
train people for those jobs
while not cutting these essential services
that keep people afloat.
- You were governing now
which was very different
from campaigning.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- So (laughs) talk a little
about that dichotomy.
And, importantly, when you're
running for reelection,
you're running against Mr. DeVos--
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- Who is, I guess, the husband--
- The husband of Betsy DeVos, yeah.
- Of Betsy DeVos.
- Yeah.
- And the founder or the president of--
- Amway.
So basically you wear a very different hat
when you, you have to.
- Oh, for sure.
I mean, you campaign in
poetry, you govern in pros,
the old saying goes.
And honestly, you really
don't know what it's like,
when you're campaigning
you're motivating people,
you're enthusiastic,
you have these visions
of what you'll be able to achieve
and sometimes the reality,
the rubber meets the road
when you walk in the door.
So two years after I was elected governor
and all of this stuff
had started to happen,
all this crazy started to kick in,
I wasn't even into my third year,
governor terms at four years,
but Dick DeVos declared that
he was gonna run against me
because all of this stuff
was happening, right?
Now anybody with a brain understands
that a governor doesn't
control the national economy,
the auto industry and the suppliers
are going to into bankruptcy,
that's not a governor's,
the governor doesn't do much about it
unless the governor actively
did something to promote that
but that wasn't obviously the case.
But nonetheless you're
up against somebody,
I was up against somebody who
had millions and millions,
I mean, they're billionaires,
millions and millions of dollars to spend
to persuade the citizens that somehow
Michigan's structural changes
were the new governor's fault
and so that was a really
challenging moment.
But the good news is, from my perspective,
is that I won the reelection and I won
with the largest number of votes
ever cast in Michigan's history,
and partly because Mr. DeVos himself
had a factory in Michigan
that he shut down
and opened up one in China
and people saw that as outsourcing,
Amway stands for American Way,
American Way jobs to China
and that was not readily forgiven.
- Social media wasn't a
factor yet, I assume--
- Not quite so much now.
- Yeah.
And how does that change all this?
- Oh, it's so, yeah.
- Doesn't it lower the standards even more
than they are already--
- When you say standards,
what do you mean standards?
- I mean the standards of
civility in campaigning.
- Yeah, I think that,
certainly what we're seeing
it's a much more crass
world because perhaps
anybody can play, right?
I think that there's some real
beauty in the democratization
of political discourse because
everybody can have a voice.
You just wanna make sure
that people, that some,
I don't know, some sense of
standards are, some civility,
is upheld and I worry, I mean, personally,
I worry that the example that's
being set in the White House
just degrades our desire
for the truth, for example,
I mean this relative
truth, alternative facts,
it's just so disturbing to me.
I wonder after we're done
with this period, this term,
will we get back as a nation to realizing
that some facts really are facts.
You know what, this really is a glass.
It is not a sponge.
And it's not relative.
So I hope that we will get
back to the notion of honor
and of truth and of all that,
but maybe that's just a
quaint thing on my part.
- Looking back in
dealing with these crises
and dealing with this campaign
where people are coming at you
with the strangest charges,
what are you most proud of
both as a governor and as a campaigner?
- Well, two different, that's
two different questions.
- Yeah.
- As a campaigner,
I was really proud of
the campaign that we ran
because it was really was about values.
When I campaigned it
was, I sat down before
and I try to figure out, all right, what,
really what do I stand
for, what are the values
that I stand for in order
to be able to explain
what citizens will get through governance?
So it was integrity, it was creativity,
it was excellence and it was inclusion
those were the four values I ran on.
When I did fundraisers I would
go through the four values
and I would say, here's what I'm gonna do
that will be an example of those.
And what's your return on investment
for investing in this
campaign is that you will
make sure that you have someone
who is relying on values,
that's a good return
on your investment.
So that's campaigning.
It's a different scenario.
I mean, you bring those
values into government
but it's a different scenario.
You can't just govern up in the air.
The reality on the ground
is much different now.
What I'm really proud of is that we did,
we were focused on three things:
diversifying the economy,
educating our citizens
and protecting people as we transition
from this old economy to a new one.
So I'm really proud of the fact
that we were able to start,
you can't finish everything
in two short terms,
but start the ball rolling
to bring in new sectors
in Michigan and other, we wanted to
support the manufacturing sector
but also recognize that you cannot balance
a state's economy on one leg,
you have to bring in other legs.
And so we did that.
The effort to try to get more
young people to go to college,
our goal was eventually
to double the number
of college graduates in Michigan,
that would not be able to have happened
in my term as governor,
but we wanted to get people
knowing that college was super important
or getting a certification
or getting something
that will enable you and seeing education
as a lifelong thing and not just something
that you do before you're 22.
So those kinds of things, I'm really proud
that we set the ball rolling.
And by the time my last term came around
and the last couple of years
after the Great Recession,
we actually had the fastest growth
of any state in the
country according to Gallup
in terms of our economy 'cause
we really took advantage
of the crisis to bring
in a lot of investment,
a lot of international investment.
I did 11 trips overseas to bring in
international investments.
- And we should mention that
because part of your
campaign hat was useful
as you went abroad to attract foreign--
- Totally.
- Investment
in foreign business.
- Right, selling Michigan overseas.
I mean, Michigan is an amazing state.
it's a beautiful state.
It has more miles of shoreline
than any state in the country
even more than California.
People might not realize that.
I mean, it's a beautiful state.
So being able to sell the
state to people and saying,
hey, let Michigan be your gateway,
if you wanna open your doors in the US
let Michigan be your gateway to that;
we're in the middle of the country,
we make things, we have
more engineers per capita
than any state in the
country, that kind of thing.
So it allowed me to be able to do that.
I mean, one of the areas
that we wanted to move into
was in the clean energy economy
and one of the components of that
was making auto 2.0 which
is the electric vehicle,
so we were a little ahead of our time.
But I went to Korea, I went to Japan
to get the components for the battery,
for the lithium ion battery.
So we needed anode,
cathode, separator material,
electrolyte, we had to
have those suppliers
inside of the state and we
created a whole supply chain
to be able to do that.
So those kind of things
I'm really proud of
and they've lasted so that's
really important (chuckles).
- In your Weinstock
lecture, you talked about AI
and employment and workers and so on.
And I'm curious, because
this tenure as governor
and now you're at Berkeley
has really prepared you
to think about how we
integrate technology,
not run away from it.
- Right.
- And I want you to
break that down a little
at wearing your political hat,
what are the sorts of things
that you have to think about
if we're gonna bring AI to the table?
Retraining, education, what?
- Right, so there's
been, there's been this,
in the industrial Midwest,
there has been really,
the villain has been China.
It's not necessarily been robotics.
Although people are
starting to see this now.
It's easier to campaign against China,
I mean you saw the president
do that during his campaign,
than it is against robots.
People see the benefit of robots.
They don't wanna have to lift heavy stuff.
They don't want, they wanna
learn how to program the robots.
They wanna know how to
maintain a robotic line.
And so the idea that you
can have a better job,
a more well-paying job
without breaking your back
is a really, and you can
still work in a factory.
Now there may be fewer of those jobs,
those specific jobs inside of a factory,
however, those jobs will be better paying.
That's attractive to people
because they could see themselves in that.
So the only question to me at that point,
not just to me but to everybody,
is how do you train people who
haven't had a college degree,
and it made sense for
them not to at the time,
how do you train them to be
able to work with the technology
and the technology
enhances their capabilities
rather than having them
see it as a threat.
That to me, we can actually use AI
to help retrain people in a way
that allows them to have that dignity.
There are number of examples of this
that are currently in use.
For example, the Department of Defense
has deployed this AI technology
where they're training
these naval officers
using something called digital tutor
where you, the tutor assess where you are
and assesses how you
learn and then takes them
to the next level and allows them to do it
at their own speed and their own way
in a way while they're learning,
while the machine is
learning how they learn best.
The results of those have been astonishing
and astonishingly successful.
So for people in the industrial Midwest,
who have been displaced like this,
this to me requires
creative federal response
or it could be a state by state response.
I would love to see a
competition be issued
for apps that develop
or for training modules
that are developed using AI to get someone
to be able to work with AI.
I mean, that is a great response.
I also think that our
workforce development
or workforce training
dollars which are so terribly
ineffectively spent right now.
We have something called the
Workforce Investment Act,
the Trade Adjustment Assistance Act
they're terrible, the
results are terrible.
Studies have shown that
they're not effective.
We spend billions on that.
We could redirect that money
to help subsidize wages
during a training period so
that somebody is training
for a job that they know
is gonna be happening.
On-the-job training rather
than in the classroom training
for those kind of workers is
by far the most effective.
Right now, we pay unemployment to people
to go and look for a job.
What if we paid unemployment to people
partly subsidizing those wages as well?
Flip it, help to
subsidize their employment
during that training process,
give the employer a
chance to look at them,
give them a chance to
look at the employer,
have them gain a skill and at the end
of the unemployment period
the employer can decide up or down,
the employee can decide up or down
but they'll have gained
a skill and have wages.
So there's a, I just think we gotta turn
the way we've been doing
things on its head.
- And you need a vigorous
social network in,
a social net in this context,
right, for this transition
whether it's tuition
support, whether, whatever.
- Yeah, I think that
tuition support can happen
by repurposing this workforce,
the training dollars we currently spend
that are ineffective.
The safety net can happen
by repurposing unemployment
and what we are paying for
when we pay people's unemployment, right?
I mean you have to have some unemployment
that is there not paying for training
but a large portion of it could
be used to upskill people.
There are experiments
that have been undertaken
in other countries.
For example, in Singapore,
they have decided
that they're gonna put $500 in an account,
in a lifelong learning account,
for every citizen of
Singapore over 25 years old
and they're gonna do this on annual basis.
They just started it so
they haven't evaluated it,
but the purpose is, and
Singapore as a state,
as a geopolitical entity has been viewed
as the most effectively
run entity in the country,
in the whole city state,
in the whole world,
they decided that it's
important for their citizens
to continually learn
and to have the freedom
to have a portable account
that will enable them
to upskill themselves.
We should be thinking of stuff like that
in this country as well.
Education should not be seen
as K through 12 or K through,
whether it's undergraduate or graduate,
it's gotta be a lifelong thing.
And it can't just be in
the setting of a university
or a community college, it has to be,
there has to be broader
ways of looking at it.
- I would like now to talk a little
about the two-party structure
and get your assessment
of the Republican and Democratic
ability to deal with
these kinds of problems.
And to the extent that
the Republicans fail,
why have they dominated the discourse
on what government should be doing?
- I think the president has
been extremely effective
at communicating to people
who have felt left behind.
When he talks about the forgotten American
even though he's never
experienced any of that himself,
during the campaign he went to a farm,
an off the track, I can't remember,
it was a Southern state, I can't remember
where exactly it was,
but he went to this farm
and all of the pundit class,
the chattering class were saying,
why would he go way over
there, that's crazy.
People came for hundreds of miles
in this rural place to see him
because he specifically
chose to go to a place
that was off the beaten path
and it was a huge signal
that I'm gonna see you.
To me, this is where Democrats
'cause traditionally
Democrats have been about
the forgotten American, the little guy,
the person who doesn't have money,
the person whose not got cloud.
The fact that we've allowed Donald Trump
to be the champion for that when he
still does not personally
embody it is amazing.
Now, so he has had a specific skill,
the Republican party I think
doesn't have that same skill.
I think he's sui generis.
And so the question
is, who's gonna be able
to take that mantle?
Mike Pence would never be
able to do that, right?
That's just not.
So to me, as you set up a 2020 battle,
the Democrats need to put someone up
who is authentically speaking
to people, all people,
it's gotta be about the great word all,
and you gotta have somebody who,
young people who are here, it was in,
I was having dinner last night
with a student at Berkeley
and she was saying, she
was so passionate about it,
we are craving authenticity, don't BS us,
don't give us this political speak.
This is why social media is
so empowering for so many
'cause it allows people
to speak their mind
without having to censor all of the,
to put your words in
the most political box.
The political, the people who are doing
the strategy for politics
over the past 30 years
are freaking out because
nothing that is true in the past
is gonna be true in 2020.
That usual strategy just does not work.
So people are encouraged to be,
you can make a mistake
now, you can admit it,
you can fess up, you can say,
hey, in the past, I smoked
pot or whatever it was.
You can admit to having
gone through something.
You can admit, I mean,
Stacey Abrams in Georgia
admitted to having had some
difficulty with her finances.
There are just, there's
so much you can admit to
and just be honest about.
And that next generation, the Millennials,
the Gen Z-ers, are craving people
who are just gonna be honest
and not run away from being human.
And so I think whoever
it is that is president
has to be courageous enough,
on the Democractic side at least,
or in running against Donald Trump
you have to be courageous enough
to be authentic and to speak to all people
including those that are
off the beaten track,
including those that the
political advisers would suggest,
oh, you should ignore
them because they're not
gonna vote for you anyway
or they never vote,
so don't waste your time.
That's not gonna work anymore.
- If you compare the
policies of the Democrats
in terms of, with the Republicans,
in terms of having a
rational worked out policy
of what should be done
about the integration of AI,
hypothetically, let's
say, then how do you make
that understandable to people?
In other words, how does that interface
with authenticity and the personality
of the bearer of that plan?
'Cause clearly in the last election
there was no impact in terms of
what was the laid out
program by the Clintons.
- Yeah, no, and I was on Hillary
Clinton's transition team
and on her policy group and
she had a book this thick
of very specific policies
including how to retrain for AI
and how it's integrated
in a way that creates jobs
rather than takes them
away and all of that.
And I think Democrats have got,
we always end up electing,
or at least nominating,
somebody who's super smart
and whose got the best policy books.
And so Hillary Clinton or
John Kerry or Michael Dukakis
or Al Gore all super
brilliant people, right,
but if you can't translate
what's in those books
to people's hearts and speak to their guts
then your policy book means nothing.
So you have to be able to tell stories
that resonate with
people using real people.
And so if you don't, I mean
this is true as governor,
I mean it's why everybody
always bring somebody
to the State of the Union
to the State of the State
'cause you, the way you can say,
this is why my policy is gonna work
'cause it worked for this
real person who's like you
and to give people hope that
something like that will work.
So to me, you have to have somebody
that speaks to people's heads and hearts
and that's a challenge,
that's the magical challenge.
Especially when you're
talking about AI, people,
if I went to Michigan now
and even use the words AI,
people would know what I'm talking about.
If I say robots, people
know what I'm talking about.
So we have to be able to have
language that is accessible
and take down the fear level and say,
you know what, this is
gonna create more jobs
than it's gonna take away.
Yeah, the taxi drivers
and the truck drivers
may eventually have their jobs impacted,
but can you imagine this
whole spade of businesses
that could be growing up around this?
I mean, giving people some imagination,
giving them seeds of hope I
think is really important.
- And what will make for
that possible candidate?
Background, personality, obviously smarts,
the Democrats--
- Yeah.
- Don't have a problem with smarts.
- Yeah, I think definitely
smarts but more so.
It's not personality.
It's really this quality of authenticity
causing people's hearts
to soar in some way,
the ability to speak to aspiration.
I mean, Obama did this so well,
Bill Clinton did this so well.
So whoever it is, it cannot
be somebody who's robotic,
it's gotta be somebody who gets it
and gets the deep, the
deep personal crisis
that people feel when they see
that vacant factory on their corner or,
I mean pick any other
crisis out there, right,
the healthcare situation,
a mom whose child
has sickle cell anemia and
she can't afford the copay,
somebody who has seen and has been there,
somebody who's gone
through those experiences,
to me, will be the best candidate.
- One last question
requiring a brief answer.
Looking back at your career, do you have
a single piece of advice
for students or people,
or young people planning
to go into politics?
- Well, one, if they're planning
to go into politics, great.
My best advice really is for them
to serve before you go in a role
that enables you to see people
who have gone through
crisis or who are in crisis
so that you can take
their stories with you.
- Well, on that note,
Jennifer, thank you very much
for taking the time to be here.
- You're such a great questioner.
It's great to be here,
thank you.
- Thank you.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat lively music)25:04